[Aplausos]
[Música]
en el referéndum sobre el break si los
gibraltareños eligieron permanecer en la
unión europea en reino unido el presi
cano por poco y algunas regiones
eligieron también quedarse en la unión
[Música]
pero lo de gibraltar fue de escándalo
casi todos los gibraltareños 196
decidieron quedarse en la unión euro
esto plantea un serio problema para
gibraltar si al final el reino unido-
sale de la unión gibraltar también
tendrá que abandonar su estatus
tras el break shit gibraltar corre el
riesgo cierto de perder su relación
especial con la unión europea esto
significaría controles en la frontera un
aislamiento del peñón y perjuicios para
toda la región del campo de gibraltar
que hacer entonces en este vídeo vamos a
hablar de los problemas actuales de
gibraltar y de su relación con españa y
os aseguro que son cuestiones muy muy
interesantes
[Música]
independencia de gibraltar
en varios momentos de la historia
gibraltar ha querido ser independiente
pero no ha podido porque naciones unidas
ha declarado que tienen que respetarse
los derechos de españa'
gibraltar está en la lista de
descolonización de naciones unidas pero
su origen no fue la expansión colonial
la ciudad el puerto y el peñón de
gibraltar fueron una cesión territorial
de un estado europeo españa a otro gran
bretaña hecha con condiciones en el
tratado de utrecht de 1713
una de esas condiciones es que en caso
de que gran bretaña quiera cambiar de
cualquier manera el estatus de gibraltar
españa recupera los derechos anteriores
a la cesión por esto reino unido no
puede transmitir el territorio de
gibraltar a ningún otro estado y
gibraltar tampoco se puede convertir en
independiente en cualquiera de esos dos
casos españa tiene derecho a recuperar
gibraltar pone de atención esto es
textualmente lo que dice el tratado si
en algún tiempo a la corona de la gran
bretaña le pareciera conveniente dar
vender o enajenar de cualquier modo la
propiedad de la dicha ciudad de
gibraltar se ha convenido y concordado
por este tratado que se dará a la corona
de españa la primera acción antes que a
otros para redimirla
sí
[Música]
un paraíso fiscal frente a esta
situación londres dio una constitución
otorgada a gibraltar en 2006 que respeta
su autonomía pero reserva las relaciones
exteriores y la seguridad para el reino
unido- un gobernador de la reina
comparte el poder con el gobierno de
gibraltar actualmente presidido por
fabian picardo del partido laborista el
parlamento de gibraltar tiene solamente
17 escaños y en la actualidad 10 de
éstos componen el gobierno presidido por
piccardo con ministros como los señores
garcía cortez o la señora sacramentos
nombres muy mediterráneos además el
gobierno de piccardo se encuentra bajo
la tutela del gobernador militar
británico que en la actualidad es edward
davis
el gobernador que no está sometido a los
tribunales puede por ejemplo rechazar
las normas aprobadas por el parlamento
de gibraltar si la reina no las acepta o
si el gobernador entiende que son
contrarias al buen gobierno del
territorio
al mismo tiempo gibraltar tiene un
régimen especial en la unión europea'
gibraltar no es territorio de la unión
porque no es territorio del reino unido-
pero allí se aplica el derecho
comunitario y las libertades
comunitarias salvo la unión aduanera
esto quiere decir que las importaciones
desde fuera de la unión pagan impuestos
en cualquier territorio de la unión pero
las importaciones a gibraltar no deben
pagar ese impuesto común por este motivo
las cosas importadas son más baratas en
gibraltar como por ejemplo el tabaco o
los productos del petróleo gibraltar se
ha aprovechado de esta situación de
varias maneras una de las primeras
importaciones de gibraltar es el tabaco
en grandes cantidades pero los
gibraltareños no pueden fumar todo lo
que importa por ejemplo se calcula que
en 2014 entre un 30 y un 40 por ciento
de el tabaco que llegaba de contrabando
a españa provenía de gibraltar
[Música]
y la unión europea y españa dejaron de
recaudar alrededor de mil millones de
euros por este concepto desde entonces
se ha regulado la venta de tabaco y su
entrada en españa pero todavía queda
mucho por hacer
igualmente gibraltar realiza pactos de
exención fiscal con empresas que se
instalan en su territorio y muchas de
ellas con oficinas ficticias para poder
operar en países de la unión europea sin
pagar impuestos fijaos bien con un
territorio de unos seis kilómetros
cuadrados en gibraltar hay inscritas más
de 20.000 empresas esto ha sido
duramente criticado por la comisión
europea que acusa a gibraltar de
competencia desleal pero el caso más
espectacular que demuestra que gibraltar
ha querido ser un paraíso fiscal es el
de las empresas de apuestas online este
caso es muy reciente ha sido resuelto
por el tribunal de justicia de la unión
europea en junio de 2017
a través de la unión europea' al juego
online en gibraltar uno de los motores
económicos del peñón lo más sorprendente
de este caso es que fue una demanda del
reino unido- contra gibraltar la
asociación de empresas del juego había
convencido al gobierno de gibraltar para
no poner ningún impuesto a los que
ganaban apuestas 'online' para favorecer
la instalación de estas empresas
mientras que en reino unido
los ganadores de apuestas online debían
pagar un 15% pues bien al final el
tribunal de la unión europea dio la
razón al reino unido y gibraltar ha
tenido que aplicar ese impuesto al final
gibraltar ha perdido numerosos casos
judiciales porque quiere actuar como
paraíso fiscal e incluso según algunos
informes aprovecharse de tráficos
ilícitos evidentemente esto afecta a la
hacienda y a la seguridad no sólo de
españa sino de la unión europea
[Música]
situación tras el break sit
en el referéndum sobre el break sheet se
demostró que los ciudadanos de gibraltar
tienen intereses muy distintos a los del
reino unido para intentar una solución
temporal a la controversia sobre
gibraltar tras el break shit españa
presentó una propuesta de soberanía
compartida al reino unido en octubre de
2016 ante naciones unidas
la idea principal es una soberanía
compartida de españa y reino unido sobre
gibraltar que mantendría su autonomía
sobre asuntos locales en esta propuesta
se permite a los gibraltareños guardar
la nacionalidad británica y adquirir
además la española una gestión conjunta
de la seguridad y las relaciones
exteriores y la pertenencia de gibraltar
a la unión europea no sé vosotros qué
pensaréis amigos de visual político qué
pensarán los gibraltareños pero a mí me
parece que esta propuesta tiene tres
grandes ventajas primero una
normalización de las relaciones de
gibraltar con su entorno y la apertura
de la frontera segundo el relanzamiento
económico del campo de gibraltar y de
toda la región con el uso conjunto del
aeropuerto y tercero los gibraltareños
ya no tendrían que elegir entre o ser
británicos o ser españoles porque pueden
ser los dos y lo que es más importante
ser ciudadanos de la unión europea
en cambio el escenario opuesto una
ruptura de relaciones con la unión
europea supondría mayores controles
fronterizos y un posible aislado
del peñón y esto afectaría por supuesto
a los más de 8.000 trabajadores que
desde españa se desplazan cada día para
trabajar en el peñón en definitiva sería
malo para todos lo preocupante por lo
preocupante que haya influido en la
frontera que es un tema más schengen que
precise pero se ha sido plan nuestro de
cada día de 35 años que llevamos con la
frontera abierta desde el 85
[Música]
encaje constitucional
la propuesta española de cosoberanía
subraya que se respetarían las
tradiciones y la cultura de gibraltar
además indica también que el régimen
nuevo de gibraltar podría insertarse en
la constitución española de 1978
hoy estamos delante del parlamento
español y bajo la estatua de cervantes y
hemos venido aquí para encontrarnos con
ainhoa lópez licenciada en derecho
público y presidenta de la asociación
cultural alonso martínez o la innova que
está le estás
quería preguntarte en primer lugar las
nacionalidades históricas y las regiones
según menciona nuestra constitución como
hicieron sus estatutos de autonomía es
muy fácil a través del artículo 143 de
la constitución se elaboró el marco para
que estas regiones estas nacionalidades
elaborarán su propio estatuto y así se
conformarán recto cumpliendo los
requisitos como comunidades autónomas y
además de estos estatutos de las
nacionalidades y regiones existen otras
posibilidades en nuestra constitución si
en el artículo 144 de la constitución
existen tres apartados como para
ciudades como ceuta y melilla y en este
sistema sería posible integrar el caso
de gibraltar si claro de hecho la
constitución lo prevé así en el artículo
144 esa amplitud está hecha precisamente
para poder implantar aquel altar dentro
de la constitución muchísimas gracias
ainhoa gracias muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros en visual político para qué
es
el artículo 144 de la constitución
establece que las cortes generales
mediante ley orgánica pueden por motivos
de interés nacional autorizar o acordar
un estatuto de autonomía para
territorios que no estén integrados en
la organización provincial el break sin
amigos inteligentes plantea un reto muy
grave para gibraltar sus ciudadanos y
sus empresas pueden quedar fuera de la
unión y al margen de las libertades
comunitarias los gibraltareños deben
resolver la contradicción en la que se
encuentran por un lado dicen que quieren
ser europeos y por otro han dicho que no
quieren que reino unido- negocio en la
cosoberanía con españa ricardo asegura
que gibraltar no aceptará la cosoberanía
cuando en realidad tras el presi de la
única manera que los gibraltareños
tienen de regularizar su situación en la
unión europea es yendo de la mano de
españa
esta solución aportaría beneficios para
todos supondría el relanzamiento
económico de toda la región sobre todo
hay que evitar aislamientos y bloqueos
y soluciones ganadoras para todos para
que se entienda en la lengua de
shakespeare y de win win situation
gibraltar podría aprovechar la propuesta
española de cosoberanía y buscar
soluciones imaginativas para resolver
esta controversia histórica entre españa
y reino unido en fin
cervantes y shakespeare deberían
entenderse como buenos amigos
hasta la próxima inteligentes
[Música]